Je ne comprends pas que tu sois d'
humeur si susceptible, je vais bien, je veux juste aller au
concert, ouais, la seule raison pour laquelle j'ai
eu les billets, c'est parce que tu as dit que tu
voulais y aller,
je suis désolé, mon garçon, je  je viens de changer
d'avis, bon ami, je le ferai, j'avais
hâte de partir avec toi, c'est
juste que je ne suis pas à la hauteur, d'accord, je
pense que tu perds tout intérêt pour moi
à cause d'Abe Lucas, oh mon Dieu, Roy, nous avons
eu  cette conversation est tellement de fois qu'il est
un ami, tu irais bien s'il était
plus qu'un ami oh ouais, s'il te plaît, ne
discutons pas de Jill, c'est tellement évident que c'est
évident tu sais ce qu'il ne se
passe donc tu es paranoïaque, ok, ok, eh
bien, je'  Je vais juste aller au concert Mike, on
s'amuse tous, on se fait un bonbon.